I had my first challenge when I tried out for the cheerleading squad...
...and they told me I was too big.
Even though I have now signed with an agency...
...that's considered one of New York's top ten modeling agencies,...
...my parents still think I'm too fat.
My body shape is curvy.
It's so hard to compare yourself to someone six foot tall and a size two.
We look at the magazines, we look at TV...
...and it's just a whole bunch of non-reality.
It's ingrained in our heads that if we lose weight, then we're beautiful.
It's really strange, there are some people who get really mad and they're like,...
..."You're not a plus-size model; you're a model."
But what they don't see personally, for me,...
...is that I love being called a plus-size model.
I think the term "plus model",...
....I don't want to take it away.
I think that it's empowering.
It's what I am.
I'm happy knowing that when I was growing up,...
...I couldn't find clothes in my size.
And now, because myself and other friends who are my size are working,...
...there are more options for us now.
It's not about being a certain size...
...but it's just about loving your body no matter what it is...
...and where you are.